nearly 60,000 travelers are stranded in
Indonesia today after a volcanic ash
closed Bali's International Airport
time-lapse video shows clouds of thick
smoke more than 13,000 feet above mount
agung 100,000 people were told to
evacuate near this volcano the highest
alert level is now in place Rebeca
henskee with our partners at the BBC is
in Bali near the volcano Mount Agung is
sending out thick clouds of ash smoking
gas behind me with increasing intensity
the airport here in Bali has been closed
for a second day because of this threat
of an imminent eruption from the volcano
at night which is in just a few hours
time we were able to see a red glow of
the lava in the crater assigned
volcanologists say that the molten and
lava has risen to the top and shows that
a full-scale eruption could be soon the
government has told people to get out
from an area a 12 kilometer radius area
saying it's no longer safe but when we
went in there today people are still
living there going about their business
reluctant to move away from their homes
and their livelihoods but the government
is saying that they do need to get out
and they may be forcibly evicted as an
eruption they say is imminent back to
you in the studio Nora all right Rebecca
henskee in Bali thank you